et pour en parler nous sommes avec
florence haye et fondatrice de
l'association victoria est donc personne
vulnérable bonsoir madame merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous nous apportez votre
témoignage en direct sur rt france on a
entendu le pdg dans perdirent de nous
excuser pas avant d'avoir été jugé
que lui répondez vous
bien c'est difficile parce que nous
famille constate ont énormément de
dysfonctionnements dans les états
lorsque nous malheureusement nous sommes
dans l'obligation de placer un autre
parent et lorsque nous nous rendons
fréquemment
visitez notre parent on ne peut que
constater les dysfonctionnements les
situations de maltraitance
donc voilà les manquements graves les
maintenant à la sécurité la non
assistance à personne en danger tout ça
je l' ai vécu et tout ça je peux en
témoigner puisque ma mère a quand même
fréquenté deux ehpad donc dans le var à
raison de trois ans pour chaque ehpad et
dans chaque est pas 2,5 et la
catastrophe et des constats alarmants
des constats ou désastreux de mauvaise
prise en charge de la nyanga vécu des
situations très difficiles des chutes à
répétition au d enfermement dans la
chambre parce qu'elle était un peu
énervé donc dans le noir avec une
chaleur épouvantable puisque nous étions
en était qu'il n'y avait pas de
climatisation dans la chambre elle hurle
elle appelé au secours et voilà il était
seul voilà comment j'ai pu retrouver ma
mère mais j'ai pu aussi voir des
résidents perdu dans le jardin faut
savoir que dans une d'engins les ehpad
le jardin était excentré par rapport à
la pièce de vie et donc les résidents
partait dans ce jardin les soignants ne
les voyait pas forcément et donc qu'il
restait dans ses jardins en plein soleil
parce que c'était les quais personnes
devenues les voir et voilà ils avaient
ils n'étaient pas protégés du soleil
n'avait pas à boire et combien de fois
je suis venu en aide voilà ses résidents
je les ai milan sécurité pour certains
je suis tellement le jardin il n'y avait
personne pour l'histoire briller enfin
voila j'ai aussi vécu une situation de
d'attouchements sexuels dans un les
ehpad que ma mère a fréquenté jeu les
dénoncer à la grèce notamment donc à
travers des courriers que j'ai pu
envoyer j'ai fait une une dénonciation
auprès du procureur de la république qui
est resté sans suite auprès de la rs
rien n'a changé c'est madame excusez moi
parce que je reste un petit peu sans
voix de ce témoignage nous avons donc
fait une un signalement à la rs pour
vous à rien répondu les choses n'ont pas
changé
les gaziers en grain pour - il ya eu une
enquête
alors je crois bien que oui puisque un
personnel avec qui je m'entendais très
bien là médicaux unis un jour il y avait
eu des inspecteurs qui était venu et
c'est bien mais pour autant je et j'ai
vu quelques améliorations très légère
amélioration
et puis par la suite tout a repris voilà
en situation de
dysfonctionnements fin à nouveau j'ai
constaté des problèmes à nouveau j'ai
constaté que la personne qui a exercé
les attouchements sexuels donc un
résident qui était lui même atteint de
maladie d'alzheimer continuer à exercer
ces violences sexuelles sur des
résidentes qui est âgée de 80 85 90 ans
donc que des dames qui était entré dans
cet ehpad qui quand même
dont on peut penser que dont elle allait
être en sécurité protégé par la
direction est en fait ce n'était pas le
cas et toujours évidemment je dirais la
totalité d'entre elles ne les avait
jamais connu de violence sexuelle il
fallait qu'elle entre dans un débat pour
connaître ça et on n'a rien fait c'était
au vu et au su de tout le personnel le
voyez mes cadres santé le voyez la
directrice mme voyer les familles quand
elles veulent est pouvait le constater
aussi donc et voilà une personne n'a
rien fait j'ai dénoncé les faits et
pourtant rien n'a changé ça a continué
voilà c'est extrêmement élevé d'agent
polyvalent d'alizée de ça je suis outré
gens qu'on n'est pas
qu'on ne soit pas intervenu que les
autorités de tutelle n'ai rien fait je
les déclarer je vois là je pense que bon
il faut aussi croire les familles ne
font pas ça pour leur plaisir et font ça
pour le bien être déjà de leurs proches
et puis aussi des résidents qui sont
dans le même ehpad dans lequel est placé
un membre de sa famille donc voilà
entre famille justement puisque vous
faites partie d'un collectif comment
vous nous expliquer ça est-ce que vous
avez des pistes vous qui connaissez bien
malheureusement ce ce sujet
alors on a essayé de créer des
collectifs notamment dans l'autre est
allouée tué ma mère mais on s'aperçoit
qu'il est très difficile de rassembler
les familles parce qu'elle lui disent
qu'elles ont peur qu'on s'en prenne à
leurs parents ils ont peur des
représailles
elles ne veulent pas porter plainte
lorsqu'elles constatent des manquements
graves
manquements graves à la sécurité
enfin voilà ça peut concerner plusieurs
domaines et elles n'osent pas porter
plainte elles n'osent pas contacté les
autorités de tutelle parfois ne les
connaissent même pas ne savent même pas
que ça existe
et du coup
les problèmes
continuent à exister ou salut des ehpad
et on a beaucoup de mal à faire bouger
les familles qui se plaignent important
mais qui finalement ne vont pas aller au
delà voilà vraiment des craintes à agir
voilà au delà de ça florence et y est
vous avez entendu le premier ministre
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nous dire
voilà on va prendre le problème à bras
le corps vous le croyez qu'est ce que
vous attendez aujourd'hui du
gouvernement
peg est une vraie prise en considération
des personnes âgées lorsqu'elles sont
placées on n'est pas qu'on leur accorde
eu du respect qu'on entend surtout les
familles puisque de toute façon les
familles sont les porte parole des
résidents les pales puisque bien souvent
pour la plupart elles ont des
difficultés à exprimer faire le bal être
les situations de maltraitance aux fins
dont elles sont victimes
donc cesser les familles qui doivent
rapporter tout ce qui se passe on n'est
pas des qui doivent se faire le porte
parole de leurs proches de la paire de
leur mère et on ne doit pas les laisser
souffrir enfin les vivres les dernières
années de leur vie dans de telles
conditions voilà et surtout moi je ne
crois que jean cassel devrait quand même
assister les autorités de tutelle à
entendre les familles lorsqu'elles ils
se plaignent est allé vérifier contrôler
les ehpad lorsqu'il y à des
dénonciations tels que j'ai pu faire
j'en ai fait les dénonciations parce que
ma mère dans le second et padoue a lutté
elle a été victime d'une fracture
de l'épaule
personne n'a relevé c'est moins l'après
midi quai constater que ma mère avec mad
mois et jean michel est un achat mère je
me dis oui bon on va pas l'envoyer aux
urgences pour ça on voyez pas pascal gil
ex et donc je suis parti et enfin la
prime dealer qui revient m'appeler parce
qu'on est les habiller notre maman
lorsqu'on la mise en chemise de nuit on
s'est rendu compte qu'elle avait le bras
bleu noir et c'est pourquoi on voit
violence et lorsque je suis arrivé aux
urgences j'ai vu le médecin urgentiste
qui m'a dit bah écoutez votre mère a
fait une chute et lorsque j'ai
reçu entretenu donc avec le directeur de
nepal il m'a dit ah ben non votre mère
n'a pas fait de chutes et personne ne
nous a relaté que votre maman avait fait
une chute de ma mère était complètement
un potentat les cacas pablisme élevé
elle était vraiment au bout de sa vie
voilà invité à la merci des
aides-soignants donc pas rare donc c'est
certainement le fait d'une maladresse
d'un manquement à la sécurité de la part
d'un soignant qui a fait que ma mère est
tombée probable de son lit le matin
voilà lorsqu'il a pris en charge pour la
toilette qui l'a remise sur son fauteuil
et qu'il y avait c'est comme ça donc il
ya une non assistance à personne en
danger j'ai porté plainte auprès du
commissariat de police et pour autant il
n'y a pas eu de suite et quand je me
suis adressé louafi et l'unsa fieldy
m'écoute voilà ce qui s'est passé à une
blague bien sûr que c'est une que c'est
qu'une chute ça peut pas vous être dû à
autre chose qu'à une chute donc voilà
donc au tout le monde et lorsque je me
suis adressé au chirurgien qui avait
opéré ma mère il m'a dit évidemment que
c'est dû à une chute donc voilà et quand
j'ai interrogé le médecin coordonnateur
de l'ehpad et le directeur ils m'ont
tous les deux qu'ils que ces petites
fractures spontanées qui n'existe pas en
tous les cas pour les membres supérieurs
sur toute manière même si le terme est
plus de six mois le savait plus rien
faire merci en tout cas florent soyez
pour ce témoignage voilà émouvant et
disons le extra choquant un merci à
jouer en tout cas d'avoir d'avoir
témoigné sur l'antenne d'arte et france